a growing trend in the last couple of
years is what some refer to as lifestyle
games where are games designed to be
replayable on a daily basis thanks to a
repetitive loop and constant updates as
such a games endgame content becomes an
important factor for many players and
recent games like destiny to have been
turning off a lot of people thanks to
its bare-bones end game along with some
other things so in comes monster hunter
which has actually been doing this exact
kind of gameplay design ever since its
inception in 2004 but a lot of people
here in the West are brand new to
monster hunter and with lifestyle games
being the in thing right now you're
probably wondering what exactly Monster
Hunter world's endgame content is like
obviously there will be spoilers so if
you want to keep your monster hunting
experience a surprise turn this video
off
and part of that it's because it's not
so simple that I can just break it up
into the main game and then the endgame
grind the way destiny or the division
kind of works rather the game weaves as
a repetitive loop throughout the whole
game and it's story is broken up into
arcs that layer more stuff over time the
first arc of the game is where the
majority of its story takes place you're
introduced to four different
environments and most of the monsters at
a pretty consistent pace that will take
you roughly 30 hours after you resolve
the plot involving the Elder Dragons or
a manga rose the game's second arc opens
up and this is where the endgame begins
to show itself with the high rank
content each environment now has a high
ranked option featuring tougher versions
of every monster changes to Monster
locations and even brand new monsters
hunting high ranked monsters and etsu
brand new materials needed to unlock
more weapon upgrades and high rank armor
sets the armor sets are new improved
versions of the low rank sets along with
completely new sets as well each set has
a alpha and beta version apart from some
small visual differences the alpha set
will typically come with a second skill
on each piece while the beta set comes
with a slot for gems gems offer more
customization in the attributes for your
armor but you'll have to put in the work
to find and craft them high rank armor
also has the nice bonus of color
customization continuing the narrative
pits you against monster variants such
as the pink rathian and leaves you to
the game's fifth and final area the
elders recess here you'll get access to
a whole new set of monsters and
materials along with a ton of optional
quests and it all leads up to a showdown
with the elder dragon near geget a all
of this will likely take you another 20
to 30 hours
but even that is not the end you'll be
given even more optional quests and a
new challenge to find and slay three
elder dragons these are the game's
toughest challenges and you'll need to
put in a lot of work upgrading your gear
and maybe even calling in some friends
if you want to take them down
how long this will take you depends on
you as a player but it seems to be
taking most people around 30 to 40 hours
which means you'll likely have put in
100 hours in to monster hunter world at
this point and no that's not even the
end one final challenge awaits in a
special area before the credits finally
roll okay so you're about a hundred
hours in and you've now just reached the
end game damn well a third tier of
monster difficulty is unlocked and they
mean some serious business but they're
worth fighting because doing high rank
investigations for them unlocks you
extreme stones stream stones are what
you use to augment your weapons and gear
when used on a weapon the stream stone
will let you upgrade either its attack
affinity defense slot upgrades or health
regen augmenting armor allows it to be
further upgraded past its normal defense
cap the trick is while stream stones
will drop from doing these
investigations you need the warrior
stream stones to upgrade weapons and
they have a very low chance of dropping
not only that but an individual stream
stone will only apply to specific weapon
categories so get ready to pray to are
in Jesus if you want that stream stone
that specifically applies to your dual
blades and that right there is the final
big hook of the game your mileage with
this is of course gonna depend on you
whether it's playing with friends until
you get bored or trying to upgrade every
single weapon and armor you can find you
can easily put in another 50 hours if
you're just trying to get a couple
things upgraded and of course there are
those diehard Monster Hunter fans who
easily put 500 to a thousand hours into
a character but is there anything more
coming post release content is planned
and it's all going to be free limited
time event quests will offer new
challenges and gear the first new
monster is planned for the spring the
fan favorite deviljho while it hasn't
been officially announced yet some fans
are hopeful that they'll be adding in
the G rank which is the highest year of
rank in
dear hunter we can expect more updates
over the year but the devs have gone on
record saying that monster hunter world
is not going to be a service game the
way destiny is its updates will come to
an end but honestly with how much the
game has to offer you'll easily be able
to sink a hundred plus hours into a
single character and that sounds pretty
good if you ask me
[Music]
and then of course you could just like
yeah start a new character charge blade
seems pretty cool I might I might try
that
you know the switch Jack seems kind of
rad you know I really didn't mess with
the bow gun that much
[Music]